We have talked a bit about the human visual
system. Let’s have a look at the way some
other animals do it.
Consider the case of the bee. The bee is a
very small animal and therefore it has got
a very small brain. The bee’s brain weighs
just one gram and it has only got 106 neurons.
So contrast that with the human brain, which
has got one and a half kilograms of grey matter
and 1011 neurons. The bee brain is much smaller,
much simpler, yet it is still able to do very
complex tasks based simply on the information
that comes from its eyes.
Now we have two eyes and the bee has two eyes.
There is nothing that says that all animals
have to have two eyes. So this is a close
up of a spider and this particular spider
has got four eyes and I think there are some
spiders that have got five eyes. So evolution
has come up with many different designs of
eyes themselves, and configurations of eyes,
that clearly confer some particular advantage
to the organism that is carrying them.
Here is a close up photograph of the eyes
of an insect. These are compound eyes, made
up of a number of polygonal facets.
Here is another type of compound eye. This
one doesn’t have quite the field of view
of the one we just looked at.
Here is the eye of a nautilus, which is quite
a primitive ocean-going animal. And the eye
really is a very simple pinhole camera; it
doesn’t have a lens as such.
Here are the eyes of a scallop. So the blue
objects that you can see, each of those is
a very simple eye and it has got a large number
of them around the outside of what is effectively
its mouth. Each of these eyes is a bit like
a reflecting telescope. The inside of those
blue objects is quite shiny and so incoming
light rays, instead of refracting in through
a lens, reflect off the shiny surface inside
that eye and fall onto the photoreceptors.
So this scallop, it uses reflection rather
then refraction and it has got a very large
number of eyes.
This is the eye of a squid and it has got
a lensed eye like we have, and it has evolved
completely independently of the lensed eye
that we have.
And here is a close up of the eyes of a bird.
The compound eye in the insect contains a
number of facets; individual light sensing
elements called ommatidia and if we look at
a cross-section of the ommatidia it has got
effectively a lens on top which funnels any
light that falls on it down inside this conical
cell which contains the light sensitive chemicals,
which emit a neural pulse when light falls
on it. So each one of these is effectively
a single pixel camera, or we can think of
it in those terms. And we have a whole array
of them pointing in slightly different directions
and that allows the insect to create a fairly
large field of view.